[音楽]
今日はプラウアンバサダーの
種本まり子です
こんな広い会場でなかなか緊張しますね
そうだこんなときにですね実は私を助けてくれる動画があるんです
ちょっと待ってくださいね
これなんですね
ちょっと落ち着きましたはぁ
リラックスできましたなんとなく会場の雰囲気も変わりましたね
この赤い花これをつけるとですね例えばこんな事が起こるんです
そう
こんな風に表情がどんどん変わっていくんですねー
さあですね
実はこの赤い花これは世界で一番小さい仮面と言われています
たからで
皆さんはどんな加盟をつけてますか
かめえっ
や仮面と祝いでもついてないなぁとか
もしかしたらギョッとされている方いるかもしれません
人間は大人になればなるほど
何かしら加盟をつけて生きるようになっていくんです
もともとはまわりの人と上手くやりたいのに
時としてそれを自分で苦しめてしまうことがある
実は私は30代のときに過度のストレスにより
鬱になりました
当時私は幼稚園の先生として子供と一緒に生活してました
保育者としていい先生でなければいけない
イライラしちゃいけない子供をこっちゃいけない
後輩から見て余裕のある先生じゃいけなきゃいけない
栗東余裕たっぷりの先生を演じる日目をつけていたんだと思います
本当は辛くて苦しいのに
自分は大丈夫
そんな日目をつけていたんです
だから瓶の中には
本当は辛いのに大丈夫という大丈夫か迷
より良く見せようとするかっこつけたがり屋の日目
いい子でなきゃいけないと言う
に子ぶりっ子の日目そんな仮面があるんです
そんな辛い時でした
映画パッチアダムスのモデルとなった
タッチ本人に会ったんです
映画弦ストーリー彼の映画をたまたま見て私は自分を変えたいと思って彼に会えに行き
ました
こんなに大きい人で彼は私を見つけて
きゅっと抱きしめてくれました
そして
クラーンになる秘訣教えてくれたんです
真梨香
クラウンになるために大事なことがあるそれはクレイジーになることだ
全く意味が分かりませんでした
クレイジー
だって私たちが訪問した先の病院では
抗がん剤の影響で髪の毛がなくなっている赤ちゃん
手も足もないそのままの状態でペットに行っている言葉たち
数百人と衣類施設の中でほとんど自由がなくなっている子どもたち
そんな子どもたちを見てクレイジーところか
なんてかわいそうなんだろう
私が何とかしなくちゃって思ってました
まだいい先生の加盟をつけていたんだと思います
でもねパッチは違ったんです本当にクレージ
だってねすごいくだらない遊びをして
でも気付いたら周りの大人たちがどんどんずれに巻き込まれて終わらしていったんです
そして
ペットの上で鬱々としていた患者さんが
くって起き上がったりすごくいい表情になったり
私はそんな瞬間を何度も見てきました
だからパッチがいうクレイジーという意味は
自分自身が楽しむこと幸せになること
そうすることで周りの人たちに良い影響を及ぼすんだ
それが言いたかったんだろうなって思いました
それを助けてくれるのがこの赤鼻
開く花をつけていると
鏡に映った自分も
周りの人たちはなんだかおかしくてほんとバカバカしいけど
そのばかばかしさを楽しめるんです
何だろう
そして全身のちからがこう抜けていくようだったんです
もしかしたら肩肘張ってきていくことなんかないんじゃないかな
そう思えたんです
そしてこの赤花を付けることで
私は赤ちゃんだったあの頃のことを思い出したんです
ハイハイしてってもう自分の興味のまま高知市のままに走っていく自分
それから転んでもまた起き上がって立ち上がっていく自分自分は何でもできるんだと
信じてやまなかったとき
あの頃のままでいいのかもしれない
この開く花を付けることで
そんな感覚が戻ってきました
好きなものは好きって言う
嫌なものは嫌だって言う
たとえ相手の位が上だろうが髪の毛引っ張ったり耳引っ張ったりやりたいことをやる
道端に咲いてる草木とだって話ができる
犬や猫とだって話ができる
そんな自分の思うままに生きていたあの頃の感覚を思い出したんです
そしてこんな純粋な赤ちゃんの心を持ったわたしたちと関わることで
それまで表情がほとんどなかったおばあちゃんが顔をくしゃくしゃにして喜んだり
と車いすに座っていたおじいさんが立ち上がって一緒に踊り出したり
それまでは時計の針が止まってたところからまた動き出していくような瞬間に何度も
立ち会いました
皆さんの中にも覚えがありませんか
自分の思うままに生きている赤ちゃんと遊んだ時
何か自分の気持ちがすごく自由になったり
あなんかやってみたいなって思ったこと
私はこのクランの活動がすごく魅力的で日本でも伝えたいなって思いました
だから日本でもクラウントレーニングの高養成講座を始めたんです
ここ大阪でもこの2年ほどその口座を開きました
去年の春
聴覚に障害を持った20代の女性が
講座に参加してくれました
名前はシマちゃん
大阪のろう学校で先生をしていられます
しまちゃんはクラウニーアとても興味があったけれど
聞き取れなかったらどうしよう
口座に入っても私が名はかけたらどうしよう
そんな不安でいっぱいだったと言いました
もしかしたら
何か我慢しなきゃいけない良い子にならなければいけないという日目をつけていたのか
もしれません
その日シマちゃんは氏はを使
そして補聴器をつけて実習に参加してくれました
とっても勇気がいることだったと思います
その日が終わって私はシマちゃんに聞きました
しまちゃん頭だった
しまちゃんは言ってくれました
クラン楽しかったよかったってっ
そして続けてこう言ってくれたんです
私は自分の人生でずっと迷惑をかけちゃいけないと思ってた
自分が何か聞くと相手の人が嫌な顔したり
何度も聞き返されたりしてずっと辛い思いをしてきた
だからこの講座に来たらきっと迷惑かかるんじゃないかと思った
でも
参加者のほかの人たちがすごく自分を温かくしてくれて
諦めないでこの講座に来て良かったと思いましたって言ってくれました
私は
それを聞いた時に胸が締め付けられるようでした
20代の女性としてやりたい事があっただろうに
通して障害を持ってるって言うだけで自分の事を我慢しなくちゃいけないの
その人がその人らしく生きて権利があるんだ
だから私はシマちゃんに言いました
しまちゃん星ねあなたが生きづらさを感じているとしたらそれはあなただけの責任じゃ
ない
それはこの社会を一緒に作ってるあたしたちの責任でもあるんだ
だから一緒に社会を変えていこう
あなたがこのクラウンのクラスに来てくれることは私たちにとってもとっても入りが
ある
本当に来てくれてありがとう
熱く語っている自分がいました
20代の女性がやりたいことをやれないなんてもったいないじゃないですか
人にはその人らしく生きる権利があるんだ
私はそれを強く心から応援したいと思いました
その日から私たちチームは新しくスタートしたんです
できないことを悔やむのではない
だったらどうしたらいいか
芝チャーや参加者全員と一緒にさんが考えました
信頼関係を深めるワークをしたり感情表現思いっきり
表したり夢中になって子供みたいに遊んだりー
そして実習の最終日
私たちは
こんなクランの衣装を着て
この町の人たちと触れ合うことにしたんです
しまちゃんは
その日よ
すごく不安を迎え持ちながら迎えたといいます
何か聞かれたらどうしよう
聞かれぬ聞き取れなかったらどうしよう
でもシマちゃんはその不安を吹き飛ばすように
自分でウサギの指人形を持ってきて子どもたちの中に飛び込んでいったんです
すると子供がこのウサギの指人形
とっても喜んでくれた
だから氏は茶はこっちの子供それからあっちの音の中に飛び込んでいったんです
パレで蛹が蝶のように飛び立つように
すごく感動的でした
終わってからシマちゃん私にこう言ってくれました
言葉ってなくても伝わるいや
それがわかったら
自分からどんどん取り込んでいきました
また一方壁を踏み越えられたような気がしてます
その日からシマちゃんは自分のやりたいこと
行きたい場所へ飛び立って行ったんです
自分の中に抑えていたものをこの赤鼻のパワーを使って自分の思うままに生きてい
そんな仮面をつけることになったんです
それまで諦めていたこと
でもそんな必要ない
それを助けてくれるのがこの赤鼻なんだと思いました
私はそんな島茶を見て
30代初めてくらあに出会ったときのことを思い出しました
いい保育茶になければいけないいい人になければいけない
周りの人を知らねせいにしなければ私は幸せになっちゃいけない
みんなから嫌われる
そんなことをずっと思って私は大丈夫という日目をずっとつけてました
そんな時でしたこのクーラーの活動に出会って
自分の思うままに生きていいんだまるで校
扉が開いたようでした
私はこれまでこのクラウンまりちゃんとして世界中の病院や施設被災地を回って
1000人以上の人たちに会ってきました
スペインにも入ったモロッコにも入ったアメリカにも入った
チベットにも入ったでも言葉が全くわからないんですねうん
でも女陰が何か分からなくたってお互いわからない同士
どうやったら分かり合えるかそしてそれを1両でも分かったらこんなに最高の幸せは
ない
9ラーニングというのは相手に何かを施すんじゃない
分かり合えないでもそこがスタートでどうやったら分かりあるかお互いそれを一緒に
つくっていくものなんだ
それをアフリカの大事で出会った人たちから教えてもらいました
肌の色が違ったっていい障害持って立っていい国が違ったっていい
みんな違うから面白いんです
パッチが教えてくれました
赤花をつけることクラーになることは
誰とでも仲良くなる一番の近道
知らない人と友達になれる近道なんだよって
子供心を持っていろんな人に関わるから誰とでも分け隔てなく関われるのです
そして
自分自身とも仲良くなれるのです
自分の気持ちてこうだった自分てこうしたいんだ
自分の感情ってこうなんだ
あー自分はここにいていいんだー
それをこの開く花をつけてくれることを教えてくれるんです
そしてこんな純粋な気持ちを持った人は関われるからこそ相手の人に何かを起こすこと
ができるんです
改めて皆さんに聞きます
あなたは
どんな仮面を付けてますか
あなたはどんな加盟をつけたいですか
愛情たっぷりのカメ勇気もりもりの画面
友達大好きの瓶
どんな画面でもつけられるんです
今あなたが生きづらさを感じているとしたらその加盟を外して他の瓶をつけることも
できるんです
今あなたが自分の気持ちに気がつかなかったら
赤ちゃんが名をつけてあの頃の自分に戻ってあの頃の自分が教えてくれることがあるん
ですよ
私たちプランは
この赤い花を付けて
いつでもあなたのことを待っています
あなたがより自分らしく自分の人生を生ききるように
あなたは
どんな画面をつけたいですか
ありがとうございます
[拍手]